we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 david p
here's something i've actually heard
from a bunch of people about mask
wearing listen to this
hey david so everybody who works in my
office takes the
coronavirus pandemic seriously uh when
they're outside the office
but then once we get inside they all
take their masks off
they're not worried about social
distancing or anything like that
and i'm the only one who keeps my mask
on keeps hand sanitizing
you know um how bad do you think
that this false sense of safety is
contributed
to the chronovirus spread hugely and i
i've heard from this from other people
i'm really good with my mask it's mostly
red states i'm pretty sure that in blue
states every every place says you've got
to have a mask on uh
at a place of work indoors it's a
generalization blue and red states but
i've heard from people who who work in
arkansas for example south carolina
south carolina is another example
that uh begrudgingly you know outdoors
um people will wear masks they'll wear
them at the grocery store etc
but but then at their place of work they
take them off and
even if you work with only eight people
and each of those eight people
is only interacting at home with two
others you're still exposed to
dozens of people's contacts and i know
of many people who have gotten
sick this way and again most of the
contagion is happening within homes
and at places of work particularly
indoor places of work so i don't really
get it
to me the outdoor is less of a priority
i'm still doing it because i'm a team
player but
the indoor particularly when you're at
work all day with people when we know
the longer you're around people
the more likely a contagion event is to
take place
i really don't get it at this point i'm
sort of beyond
trying to understand the logic that
folks are applying
to when they do and don't wear masks i i
i'm sort of at a loss but i've heard
that from many
people we've got a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about the
uh potential expedition of julian
assange we will talk about
jack ma and other chinese billionaires
mia after criticizing the chinese
government and
much much more get instant access to
today's bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com